hello everybody markiplier here back at
you with more SCP OMB I said I'd do it I
said if you guys want him I said if you
guys wanted me to do it I'd do it don't
know what that's all about
ok so some of you said or I remember
reading somewhere that um there were
voices for the month oh I'm trailing ha
ha all right huh ah fudge ah ah I
actually hit the windows button ok
alright I got this some guys said that
there are voices when monsters pop up
that tell you god I don't all right
that say like don't look at me or don't
turn around or something like that so I
gotta pay attention
oh ok I'm only at number 4 nothing to
worry about
nothing to worry about I got this I got
this guys and girls okay
ah I always take the left someone said
Oh seems to be getting more varied very
early on I also hopefully fixed the
resolution issue so won't be numb 4x3
ID I didn't realize you had to manually
create good luck
alright oh god oh god I'm too tough for
you Oh someone said that that was it ah
oh that's what I was oh no oh no I am
too tough for you I got it I got it I
got it I got it
good on it number 9 keep moving forward
forget another monster I'm just gonna
stop hammer time
hahaha
how would you like it if I breathed on
your neck buddy - like that do you like
that a lot you very much want that to
happen
Oh God ah tough for you guys up there
I got this ah beat it and beat this game
thirteen lucky lucky number
shut up we're unlucky I don't know I got
this ah railing a problem dark dark dark
okay no problem got this down keep going
keep fifteen fifteen
what the hell is that what is this what
is this what's going on there I never
seen that before
oh no sixteen there it is again what is
it what is that where what is this I
don't know I remember last time I played
17 was where things start going wrong
yep yep 1717 was the number 17 was magic
number huh huh gonna make it I think I
think I read somewhere that there are
140 floors I'm gonna make it 19 oh there
it is again what is this what is with
this I don't know I don't know 20 okay
alright I got this haha 21 Oh what's
this
take a left to the left
Oh
uh-huh huh it's a long hallway what's
going on whoa I was weird it just went
straight for a while
22 ah don't look you're behind me aren't
you you [ __ ] you're nothing oh oh no
no no oh I'm gonna make it 23 I don't
even know what the deepest I went the
first time I don't know
ah 25 I think that's a record by me by
me
no that's it oh no no no nope nope nope
nope not every mask
nope now I'm gonna ask if you want me to
play again nope nope nope nope nope nope
no no no no no no no no no no no you can
pick the wrong direction in that who the
hell said to only go laughs ah okay
anyway ah
all right so that's the end of that I'm
done maybe oh maybe I'm a glutton for
punishment now let me know let me let me
know what you thought if you want to do
it again maybe way down way in the
future
way far down that road maybe some time
am i play it again boom oh no oh no I am
done all right
so hope you enjoyed that thank you all
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye